all right we are laughs welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 68 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
I'm extremely excited about our special
guests so we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord who in my
opinion is one of the premier content
creators in the game whom I had the
pleasure of meeting in the flesh at e3
2018 this Lord's positive energy and
passion for multi-platform gaming is
infectious with everything he does
whether it be his daily news videos
detail beginners guides and behind the
scenes in real life series all done with
insightful commentary and outstanding
video production introducing the host
and co-founder of the Eric's getting
YouTube channel and contributor to the
VG 24/7 dot-com website one of the top 5
Dead or Alive V law creators in the game
and the Lord responsible for the best
beard snapbacks it loved it swag on
YouTube the wiper King making his debut
into the realm of the Lords my man Lord
Eric's gaming how you doing sir I'm good
I'm good it's great to be here I got you
that was amazing it was it was the part
thing he said introducing absolute
pleasure to have you in the room you are
definitely the Lord in your realm it's
only right that we had to show you the
proper respect here at the round are you
ready to have some fun with the Lords oh
yes no doubt man let's do it and of
course you know we have the Four
Horsemen of gaming those usual suspects
at the round table
my co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother
the difficult game Conqueror and the
howl of the young wolf my man Lord
addict are you doing sir we're doing
pretty good a little bit tired uh you
know people do sleep so you can go in
and call me Lord sleep in the good to go
but been a great day uh X calms really
can't like took over my life I'm to a
war chosen yeah then I got I got Lord
John to play Monster Hunter yesterday
again by one of the older drags he's
like I'm done I like John you gonna
leave after dying one time
shut up the big bad job ever get a
chance that's his name big batch that's
the very idea always cool games good
stuff in and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also a sastra Thomas mr.
offline profile Illuminati and Lord
patreon himself mommy
Lord sovereign how you doing sir good
man doing fantastic great to be here um
yeah wide awake just like addict uh went
yesterday watching my my Yanks get
thrashed at least you're in the running
and it's a day for you and it's not you
team is getting broken up and everyone's
gonna trade it so you you're doing quite
alright that's the only positive thing
is they open up today this day every
year to give Bobby Bonilla 1.28 the
excess gamer oh the lord of combat
sports who was a man of his convictions
demands nothing less than that premium
experience and is to get money game up
Oh
be loving Lord King how you doing sir
we're doing incredible you know this is
my day this is my day because I got my
ace punku
number one dude that I go to for my
information my mission man is on deck
I'm gonna tell you right now he was my
ace in the hole
every time somebody would tell me
something I know exactly where to go to
and what to use it couldn't refute it
because his information was 100% correct
oh let me tell you something I got no
combat sport to talk about today but if
you have not seen Luke Cage or Netflix
you are insane they took Luke Cage from
the last season and ramped it up by a
billion by a billion the first three
episodes is a little slow and they got
some stuff in there that you might not
like you're gonna toss that stuff out
because they get right to the grind and
right to the nitty gritty in the first
episode I turned it off because I
honestly think you are Jessica Jones
type of man in any you know- type of way
I think Jessica Jones will lend to what
you are looking for when you come to
Netflix for Marvel stuff this actually
lends towards uh you know like my type
of stuff you know like alpha male type
of things where it you know the music
the the aesthetics the fighting they
fixed his fighting guys you know II just
wonder like the toss fool no no yo it's
okay you shot Lawson although he says
he's loving season of Luke Cage is about
eight episodes in yeah feelin it okay
nice anything else going on that's good
but King has really been rocking the
Luke Cage I'm feeling it 0h at baby
doesn't sir and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself the shinobi law
Cognito sprite now I realize in the
realm of the IOP not telling you what
you wanna hear but what you need
here so before we get into what the
Lord's are playing this week I want to
start off with Lord Eric's this video
game system history is passion for that
shared world shooter genre gray in the
industry even a state at Microsoft I
believe yeah what eventually led him to
the creation of the of the Eric gaming
channel with his co-founder and partner
in crime I got a chance to meet
legendary to 6-9 so Lord Eric's let's
start from the beginning like what would
have some of the first video game
systems you had ooh
so style way back Sega Master System cuz
back then I was like my brother had it I
used to I used to play like on his
console it was the first game I ever
played with some Aleksic in miracle
world so I came like obviously like the
main character had the same name as me I
was like yeah this is like this is cool
and then yes I played that for a while
then my brother got an n64 so again I
kind of still like shared the console
with him but used to buy like occasional
games and then my first console that I
personally owned was the Game Boy
Advance and then a Gamecube nice a lot
of people don't like the GameCube but I
thought it was always a gotcha force
that no one knows of that I just was
obsessed with before let's go back just
a second for them I know you man system
was the firm what was some Master System
games you like then we're going to the
Gamecube getting like four you get a
gear core favorite games on those
platforms so my system would definitely
be yes Alex in America world I also
played um
Mickey Mouse cost of illusions right Oh
loving your Lord loves to this fela I
don't think I've ever still fully
completed them because those was a tough
like you get the end you die you have to
start the whole game again say this but
I went and played on emulator and it let
you saving us I can't do it I can't save
me Fester's team exactly like games back
in the day they used to be tough but
then there's also the like
pretty well no differently there's a
ninja gaiden on some awesome have like a
really cool soundtrack those ones those
one stood out but yeah I think a lot of
my most of my like big games that a
favorite games all the time come on the
n64 that was like a really really good
game
okay so give me give me someone in 64
was go substandard Ocarina of Time Zoda
is my above all like my favorite
franchise well actually franchise owned
a second okay so that's thing because
for me like cuz I grew up because I you
know was grown up it was only like where
the console was like my brother admin so
I went from there so I grew up as a
Nintendo kid like I didn't actually get
a play station until ps3 pure I went I
win same awesome 64 gamecube gameboy
advance we 3ds all ideas um and then
then finally I got a ps3 to my friend
lads thought was cool he was like yeah
you should get this and play together
and then it was when I'm at 260 or 360
so I was like online just Nintendo kid
so a large chunk of my life
Wow that's it now here's the thing
though like cuz you started you started
Sega then you kind of switch often
antenna which is a unique startup so my
question is like did the Genesis or any
of that not interested you and then also
the question I had is I know as you said
from you started that PlayStation 3 as
opposed to PlayStation 1 like did those
not interests or I'm just curious about
the gaps so for me it was I mean at that
age again it was based on like we're for
my brother got because I didn't like
when I was I was younger sorry I didn't
really becoming sweet something like
that but that's like it I think you know
at the time like he used interested in
my 64 and then kind of when we made the
switch to Nintendo just that was kind of
what we were really interested in
because again we're like with him as
well like he he played it but we weren't
really gonna be like parent Wars by
multiple consoles at that time you know
you've got the 64 and then because also
back in the day like you know parents
were spiked again cause I was a game
console right what's the difference
between this PlayStation this this n64
like they weren't they always
I know sir but I used to play into like
so much longer than it's alright because
you you buy the cartridge it's like this
is gonna outlast you for a good few
months like you're gonna play this truck
yes
where is that now you'd like you play it
hours a night yo yo Don let me move into
my next game is that some yes I just
kind of grew up with like a massive an
n64 back catalog and then obviously
because they're the games that I grew up
with like I I never really felt like I
was missing out because I was like cuz I
didn't know at the time I didn't like
none of my friends had them either like
they were all on maintenance before so
we all kind of like lived in that little
bubble so I didn't really I got you know
about the PlayStation games that much
yeah I just I just kind of know with the
franchise that bit obvious obviously
when Gamecube came out like yeah just
more love and they ain't a man but then
when we came out and they were like some
good games but then afterwards I was
like alright there's kind of nothing on
this console for a bit as a gamer we
came out with Twilight Princess things
that's why I was super slowly where I
was like it came out and I was great for
a while but once I've done Twilight
Princess
I played a few other things that I
played like some question what games
like red steel and I'm like I feel like
I need to rule in my horizons now so
then I got a PlayStation 3 on for like
the first two weeks I didn't actually
have games rear side by download all the
demos on PlayStation Network and I just
basically played demos like riding the
burnout paradise demo was so good and
then I got like a first PlayStation game
yeah that I see started off bad three
then you also said you had a 360 I swear
word now did a sixth magnitude yes yes I
got three yeah just like super late when
I left like in the UK school like sick
for them and then I saw when I lied to
university and I met two sick so that's
what we first like they're kind of cool
because like you know which we would
chat about games and stuff and he's like
now you need to get yourself a 360
because back then it's funny because the
way this all phase shifted now like back
then like Microsoft was I'd say like a
little bit more dominant in like they
code that sort of games they had and it
was out you know there was that slope
here if a ps3 for a little bit like it
had a few things that wasn't much
happening so he was like yeah get
yourself a 360
and then it was like around Christmas
time so there's like a bundle so I
bought that I've got Gears of War 2 at
the time telling Legion so I name was
kind of cool because obviously I just
met him but at the same time and then
[Laughter]
always I always will be hey you realize
every every game in this every topic
every game that's in these topics none
of them are on the swing library ever
that he but say the Tendo for life they
love UI that's the only game you need in
your life
Nintendo announced that Louise's match
is a 3ds exclusive and I'm like yeah I'm
gonna I'm not I can't go back to my suit
my shoe or 3ds now I'm just like a
console Final Fantasies on the Vita and
after I switched I was like I got it I
gotta get rid of this video I can't play
it anymore
so yeah great console is about obviously
led you to where you are as far as now
and then you pretty much got everything
so what I was like also talk about fargy
gaming history like I consider you like
the lord of like the console share world
shooter like MMO light like we talked
about offline so I want to know like
basically I know like you for some of
the best coverage on destiny like I've
ever seen on a next shot the Lord King
cuz I came across your content to uh
busy to for 7.25 and then like I seen
you kind of like go from destiny you
evolve in division now anthem so like
how did that passion thought for those
type of games like that little console
MMO like shareware shareware shooter
kind of deal so the guy was I supposed
to you know reach into those games that
she came from to six I mean cuz you know
I suppose if we saw go away that way
he's the one that actually suggested we
start the channel in the first place you
know can we first I'd like YouTube you
know is sort of more random content we
just uploaded videos for things that we
were playing and stuff but then and
obviously with two six because he grew
up playing on xbox oh yeah he grew up
with Halo it's naturally when Bungie
working on the next thing he was like he
was already here in new about so I
waited way before when they first
announced I didn't even I hadn't even
heard about it he was like yo there's
this game coming out or destiny that we
should definitely check out and I'm
alright cool so obvious I point me in
the direction and then you know the time
obviously we didn't really know like
what it was gonna be you know beyond
that point but we've obviously played
alot of mmos we used to play a lot of
water war cross a lot of other games
like that so we were into the kind of
like MMO genre and the way the latest 5
did by pre-launch obviously it looked
like it was gonna kind of fill that
space so right so we start you know we
started like pre covering it you know
this was that before it came out we
start around the Alpha and stuff so we
got like a little hands-on and then just
nice try and like do all the covers like
that and obviously wants to came out and
then we realized that we really enjoyed
because he sort of gave us that that
sort of feel that we got from like well
without having to consume like your
entire line right thanks obviously that
was kind of a turning point for the
channel because before then we used to
just cover against people playing but we
kind of didn't really have like a
schedule we would just be like well you
know we're playing this game and there
might be like a week where
but loads of games come out so we just
throw up loads of videos and they might
be like a period of time where there's
nothing that comes out so we just don't
make videos basically became the time
when we started doing daily content
because there was always something to
talk about in destiny so we already do
that so destiny kind of even though we
cover a lot of things before then we
started to grow before then destiny was
solved the first although spring right
you know this is uh this guy see I kind
of gave kick up the backside with all
right this is all we need to do it's
like what we were start covering and
then yes or it kind of led live from
there and obviously our expansions and
stuff and just kept on like the content
kind of sold made itself right there was
always people who always want to know
something you know where there's another
weapon so that's like to something right
um and then obviously because that space
started to gain traction then other
people start then division care about
again that was from 260 was like oh this
like I gave Ida kind of misty at the
time he was like y'all is this game
coming out keep your eyes on this one as
well and then that one we started a
super idea we started pre covering
division about two years before it came
out
Wow or again a cover game that only is
hella difficult because boys nothing
right cuz you're covering at that early
though once the game came out you're
probably one of the go-to people for
that because you 24 time I'm on it so
hard and you your destiny content was so
precise and it was so up to the moment
because I can't refresh him and I
catching your videos and I said okay I
get to a point I'm looking at the video
and I'm moving to TV to get to the exact
spot I said this is the cave he's
talking about and people don't know what
I'm farming but I know what I'm farming
yeah you told me and yes yeah content on
the division was insane because these
guys in this room right here don't like
the division I don't dislike you in the
beginning I didn't dislike it I did I
dislike it afterwards but they've
improved I guess my issue was the game
itself was good it was solid I guess my
only issue was just I was thinking it
was gonna have more of an in-game like
what
talking about now like it's a but they
did go on their say we remember what was
that thing called that was rumored that
was their version of the rain oh they
said it was Rikers Island and I okay
yeah I got I gotta get that King for
that one he's gonna tell you the content
was good for me he told me how to build
my character spec by spec to go into the
dogs on and not be fearful and I was
able to use and it's like your video
will be like oh you can go on to the dog
zone alone I'm like alone you be super
tanky and I say you know his content was
so incredible and the fact that you are
on today this is like a little mini cool
for myself he's like yo this is your guy
yo guys coming on to Sunday I'm like
thank God people a Loki fanboy because I
was at the you know kind of media with a
shout out the Lord Sam talked about in
the in the building the chat a note EIC
network.com
and we got media impressed and I'm like
I literally stopped what I was doing I
was opposed to go over to what does he
jump for us yeah like I said to six and
I'm like no like just to hold the whole
process but yeah man I was like dude we
got to do it he kept his word not really
a freezing yeah mess or with like I said
with the shareware shooter and you know
we know you for that and all that good
stuff
so on we got into that now I gotta get
in something you gotta help me with now
sure okay now you gotta help me because
I want to talk to you about monster hunt
all right you know saying you are the
King you know saying I want to shout out
more to Bart is I want to shout out Lord
zero Lord
Jeff Gordon from window central and Lord
Richard Foley we had a last last episode
from Wonderlab
these guys are the hugest biggest I mean
they loved one so - so much like Laura
fogey was like boom he said he was in
his all top five we could put it in all
five games Louis I guess I gotta ask you
because to be honest I'm terrified I'm
terrified it's terrible I'm afraid I was
doing a billion write that with the bill
but listen Lord addict knows we try a
lot attic shout out to you man because
he actually was holding my hand going do
it and I'm like okay so why the hell
must I log into the lobby and hope I get
hey he said go to this board and talk to
this lady and then maybe we can have a
friendship and yeah we did that for a
half an hour when we finally got to
fight one monster together and I said
this is straight because again Kings
gave me from the co-operative aspect but
all my friends are playing everyone is
gonna show was playing this game I see
the videos you do help a guy like me
understand what is the deal
when monster first came out I put like
four days straight into it first up I
appreciate so baseball King was saying
right there I would say on Xbox around
launch there were some difficulties
trying to party up so it sounds like
your your initial experience was
and also this was a weird thing because
this is the what this is the one thing
in world that they did that was kind of
junky they've never done in previous
games before partying up to play the
online thing the online story this time
around was really weird because of this
weird notion that you had to basically
watch the cutscene before you could
party up so you have this weird
disjointed thing where people would join
a question yeah you watch a cutscene
you'd leave the question you read on
again it was way sister but the thing is
that's kind of like your Quan quote
golden line once you get past that and
you've done like the story the story
means nothing in most times that's just
that's just like your your tutorial if
you will once you get one that you never
experienced that again and then and then
multiplayer is just like seamless it
seemed as it works is fine there's no
problems then you don't have any there's
issues and then you can just like study
party up the whole time and just put
everything together
think of the story is in death City
story it's a chore it's not fun because
in previous games it was actually
separated like in the handheld once you
have like an offline section that you
can only do yourself and you have the
online stuff whereas in this one they
basically blurred the lines where
everything can be done together but then
because they wove the story into it and
they were so like you know so I'll admit
like they if you're if this is your
first time with it and I did very first
experience that little bit was a big
kind of Jackie to your ass but when you
can see past it so most hunter itself
like I'm especially given that you know
coming from places like you know playing
games like destiny and stuff there's a
lot of stuff that would appeal to you so
you know you see if you see every single
Monster as like a badass boss that you
just need to like learn the mechanics
for because every single monster behaves
differently plays differently you have
to study you have to watch your egg and
then listen button because this and
because you don't have the life bar you
know it's kind of a sort of feeling that
you get when you think it wouldn't all
have to cut you but with no life more
like does it have like that like almost
like a Call of Duty damage system with a
more read on screen kind of deal no yeah
you have a monster I'm like gradually
you weaken and then you know they'll
have to tell us like you know like a
like a real why don't like oh like a
monitor itself doesn't have it so you'll
keep attacking you know then part of the
monster will break off you can cut off
the tails they like you'll start to like
limp away or start on honey it's really
weak or go and sleep so you have kind of
tells but it has like no sort of you
know sort feeling because because you're
not chipping away at health but you can
see all the time when you finally they
know dude pull off thought when you
finally defeat the foot most of the
first time it's super satisfying because
you then carve it up you get all the
parts from it you go
to the smithy abase and suddenly you can
see this almost it you can make from
this monster right and there's like a
whole three different weapons you can
make as well like ever pretty much every
monster has a weapon has like a
variation of one of the 14 weapons
there's a slight variations but
generally speaking they have them then
you have all this as well and then
suddenly so you go back and you see the
solver set you all right I need like
another 10 pieces other 10 scales in
this so you go find that monster again
and again you do that and once you
finish it you have your full-on us that
you feel badass then you're like alright
let's go how about the next thing when
you're peeling roses but every single
time you fight something new and you
come back news like yo this looks
awesome like you want to you know
sonometer
together it's just like it basically
taps into like from what you're doing
just you know in a way that you kind of
repeat by stripes to get good weapon so
your feet raised to get that kind of
stuff it taps into that future boring no
no boy let us think it's more like yeah
some of it is some of us or like mm-hmm
do require so we get a little bit
getting used to because the weapons
behavior and differently there's 14
different weapons and you don't know if
they're drastically different
yeah now what what about what about like
for example see to me what separates
destiny in my opinion is that ready
right so like I see that they have a
cooperative aspect but do they have any
like world events where multiple players
can kind of get together so you know
like there is one thing the other reason
is it's not a so it's definitely
existing a different genre I would say
always important to remember the like
while there are certain aspects you can
sort of see similarities in most time
that definitely doesn't exist in that
space per se so you're not like raised
wellness or thing that wouldn't
necessarily feeling with it that being
said they did recently release a new
activity which is like this one special
monster that has 16 people working
together but you don't actually see all
16 it's basically four groups of four
that's not really what most highlight
was going off like the similarities kind
of are linked in to saw like the loot
and the gear grinder stuff but they
don't necessarily beyond that it's a
it's more I say beyond that it shares
more similar to be something like Dark
Souls than it would say destiny because
I'm not a Dark Souls is way more
forgiving what I don't like
energy bar and I don't like the
pre-canned stuff like you shoot them and
then he'll run to a different section
and he'll fall asleep over there I just
got so sick and tired of that part right
there that I tried I tried so bad I try
with that game because it did look nice
on my ex this really looks nice but I
said it sucks so bad like no but I used
a crossbow gun that that's okay maybe
it's the weapon because I was a big
broadsword and a very early launch you
know cooperative technical issues in the
quality of life has since improved
correct what attica I think what I would
say is at least the nicely Vermont's
hunter is that if ever you do decide to
get into or get back into right the nice
thing about it is that it's the way the
way that it the Spacely existed as well
unlike something my destiny where you
kind of like you can fall behind it must
have the right leg because it's like
although it always got online there's
there is essentially like sort of an end
point you can get to and then beyond the
point you just grind wherever you want
so you wouldn't get to a point where
like if you jump in the game you la are
everybody's like ahead of me I'll never
catch up because it's not solving the
way the game works like you know for
example like in destiny if it's like I
fall behind me no activity no like
thunder because it wasn't technically
speaking most times I could go and get
like the beginner weapon to be in a gear
I'm going find something it'll take me a
hell of a lot longer but because in most
hunter it's not like you don't level up
right you're your quote-unquote leveling
up is just getting better gear so it's
just better so the nice thing about that
is it is actually quite a good game that
can sit alongside things like I could go
oh say you know they say forsaken comes
out right and I put yes I put most
hundred whole for a month yeah I'm not
gonna fall behind it's not going to like
to see that like that I don't like that
okay yeah I mean what can they do of
course they really see a ton of like
free DLC like at the moment it's been
roughly give or take every month or
month in a bit there's been like a new
most added oh is he all that's
completely free right this is like it's
just additional content I don't see you
ever eat on this and you monster there's
new gear there's new weapons stuff to do
so apart from you know when that windows
come in sometimes they come in there
permanently I did sometimes they come in
as a vent quest that rotate in and out
for a few weeks but speaking like you
know when when it does come to the point
where I have to make automatically most
handle in the world
about butter for a bit I'm not gonna
fool the height I'll just need a comma
chin and just all so that's so with that
in mind it's definitely something worth
diving into um I would say if you're if
you look it's all I play with people
like look past this all story bit
because I watched you get a part about
this it's a little bit wind junkie like
if you it is one of things that like if
the if the most hunter kind of grind and
they're on the field they get feel good
part of combat takes with you and you
will be forever hooked right now I'm
gonna ask you to two more questions in
reference to this because I'm one
obviously I'm a big switch fan
yeah and a lot of my time is on the go
on my work I have time I'm traveling a
lot source which is a big part so
obviously I know they're coming out with
a monster world ultimate I've got they
look all coverage on it and it looked
pretty solid now my question is would
that be a good beginner way for me to
kind of just get into it or a master
probably way to go like the one that's
coming to the switch you're talking
don't touch
here's the thing I mean yeah I
definitely not even did the video this I
haven't mentioned I was like you know I
did say they're like most other
generations and generations not by
extension like they're not good places
if they're your first entry point to
more time because I think thing with
those previous ones like they most fun
doesn't really have like a story that
tells you too much anywhere my previous
games have had like a little bit earlier
they were kind of work it in my
generations is very much like because it
was mister creators like a celebration
title like it had a lot of monsters from
the previous games like a lot of weapons
there listen inside the new star so it's
basically designed as like a celebration
sort of festival title that had like a
ton of content I'm talking like you know
world has got like 30 monsters this has
like you know 70 80 plus monsters rally
but you've got like hundreds and
hundreds 15s there's hundreds of weapons
workers it's basically got everything
but the problem with that is that it
drops you into the game it's like have
fun the quest but you go into your box
it's like all right here's 14 starter
weapons like alright cut out some
Cheetos guy there
[Applause]
and there's no generation they
introduced like styles as well so you
know different ways to use those
existing weapons again it's like how am
I gonna find use that equip it and go
kill something
yeah have no way of like they don't
really do marks for Hunter is like you
learn yourself you get killed 50 times
using that weapon you're probably not
using it right I do absolutely often I
don't like is an amazing game you're
like oh this this summer I realize you
know with my tongue right I've got
there's a lot of people have got into
most hunted with world and I'm like if
you if you discover what's on the world
and you've realized that you like the
game and the space exists in then you
would recommend go into generations
ultimate because then you once you have
like an understanding of like you know
this is what this game kind of offers
then you can get because the nice thing
about our world isn't that much earlier
in the game you get infused to like the
good stuff for you start hunting like
cool monsters where as in the previous
game their very first likes a couple
hours you got you're kind of doing like
these remedial tasks like going
gathering like mushrooms and flowers and
bugs and stuff and then but you do
that's gonna get other way well yeah but
in the world they introduce those like
things you can do as a long side when
you're doing main quests right so like
it's a lot more right to start your
honey something cool um so there's a lot
of you there's a lot of things are you
coming to get bossed once you do get
boss the totals there's so much stuff in
there
so I'd say if anything kind of a
recommendation I recommend for me yeah I
say if you get chance
jump a world kind of like get a feel for
the game I know that obviously ultimate
did come before so they'll be there some
quality of life stuff is produced in
world that won't be present in generics
ultimate right that's but if you if you
play what jump into the new joint and
then scale back your expectations
I'm telling you look I need you I know
you wanna throw you switch into some
serious yeah I was no in if they're
telling you they're telling you you
listen to the warning signs all right
they love this game that one size is on
the wall he's telling you don't do it if
anything I would say world's is a
tutorial for generation he's gonna
because he wants to be on the goal is
show that he has listened they buy game
showed he likes it for that epic part
where he looks through the library's
like look at all these games I know as
an experiment the only way they could
get me to do it again with the other
consoles Eric's own one by Amell or
bloody knuckles they were saying are you
excited for the summer update tomorrow
they're already and then the second shot
my man although he says how do you feel
about the belated PC launch of Monster
Hunter work you think it's gonna be as
big as before I think it's definitely
there's a lot of people that really want
to get into this this tons of people are
still asking like I get comments of
videos on Twitch and stuff like when we
hear it talked about PC there's a lot of
people that have been like that
she holdout they you know they want to
experience it on PC obviously you know
it's interesting when if you have a
staggered launch I don't feel like you
know the second launch will never be
quite as big as the first one they've
already kind of like done massive
numbers with it but I still feel still
feel there's a lot of people that will
be high written get into it so yeah I
could always be like a second win for
the game as well right so no no no doubt
all right lord zero but give you this
last question down on my frontier hello
Lord zero okay asking what your thoughts
on the Final Fantasy behemoth coming I'm
looking I'm really good for it it's a
really cool collaboration because in the
past obviously they typically do
collaborations we'd like you'll get a
call all myself like another IP or like
a weapon yeah but you actually have like
a monster physically for another game
come in really cool there's like the
speculation of kind of go as well it
looks like it's got a similar skeleton
as a monster that everyone kind of wants
to see at its the game I could one from
a previous thing because a lot of these
monsters although they behave
differently they some of them if there
are the same type of monster they'll
share the skeleton it looks remarkably
like it could have as an ogre skeleton
so I'm hoping that could maybe mean that
we get that like foe that I'm a lion but
mm-hm
beside the curiosity of what other
monster would you like to see from Final
Fantasy and in monster owner uh so
here's the is the usual fantasy there's
a monster in there Carter
amar burrow it's like a big I can't even
describe it I don't know how to describe
it to you but it pretty much shoots acid
and stuff and gives you a bunch of it's
one of the like the most famous I would
say the behemoth is one of the most
famous but I would feel like mmm that
would be a better thing to fight in it
because like it was shoot it's got a
move called bad breath and it gives you
every bad element in the game dizzy all
of that why I would like to see
something like that I feel like out of
all the final fantasy monsters they
could have picked they picked the one I
didn't want mmm good Eric's yeah like um
I
although the collaboration ones are cool
there's definitely a few that I
definitely want to sort of see come back
like I'm missing like yeah I want to
season ogre t-rex I wanna see Roger and
come back as well it's just like fellow
Nicole wants but yeah I mean I think I
think if they can do more these with
more these collaborations as well as
because uh you know so we saw free
content right so just like reasons
people's kind of chat back in as well so
it brings life yeah all right so we got
to the master hunter segment so um yeah
now I just want to get it out to your
career because um obviously I heard you
passed we had a ex role at a landing a
job at Microsoft so I wonder like would
role specifically and then also in
conjunction with that getting that
connection from where I know you on vg2
went 247 dot-com so I started Microsoft
like how did that come down what was
your role sure so again kind of worked
with two six so let's use ixnay
obviously we've met University we both
did like a kind of a game design courses
kind of badly named computer games but
essentially was like computer science
would like game design elements and
stuff a nice mmm then we left we left
University kind of did the usual thing
where you send out your applications and
then we were hit with the typical games
industry catch 2022 thing like oh you
need to have experience but you cover so
you can't have experience if you don't
get a job and then idea first he was
like you know what you know you because
we have FIFO all the positions that we
in theory qualify for life so if we
can't do that we should apply for like
testing rules because he likes you
anyway yeah exactly yeah so we did that
um and then you know like sent out some
applications of stuff and then there was
kind of one point where we kind of go so
like in fact I think he was 260 coming
over so so sick of not having like
Stevie's bounce back and stuff that we
justify for like a job that we weren't
even qualify for at Microsoft and then
maybe they got back to 260 by it but
they were like you know qualify for this
job but like there's a role here that
you might do so he went in from he went
in for an interview and he um he had
like he's crazy cuz he had like some
long like three hour interview he can he
came in as like a like like senior
tester so yes he kind of gave me level
up nothing on Forza horizon nice and
then that was like when he's like first
ice the team was super small and then
when they started ramping up he like he
brought me him he's based like you know
they were they were looking to hire
people he was like look single season
and then it's obviously I went down as
well I kind of got the interview it's
funny though because I had like a
interview like a different role so like
mine was he was like he was there for
like three hours
I'm looking forward to this I'm getting
ready for like menti preparing for like
a long in Telugu I was there for like 10
minutes there like yep cool
is that good that would be like
terrified like your my with you my dues
in here prison longer than a Harry
Potter movie why my leaves me two hours
to get there as well
Wow yes I got the job which is cool I
came in as like a genius tester so I was
working on I was also working on Forza
horizon so I was six on that and then we
started off yeah we started working in
there and then IA like what was about
three four months you know I kind of
jumped up to my senior tested so we're
both working on like Forza the team like
massively ramped up and it was during
that time that we actually launched the
YouTube channel we come adjusted it's
like fun of a man but they need to have
what they used to should have like a
games library there so we used to have
Borah games just blow make some videos
for this occasionally coming a little
bit early like on like American release
and stuff so there are great fact one of
the games actually kicked off the
channel was like they got a series wrath
and they I mean I love that game right
but like that came out like released in
America on a Tuesday and in the UK on a
Friday so that they had in the library
so we thought I will play it and we live
just uploaded like a raw gameplay of a
lie because it was basically up watching
anime
yeah and weirdly love back then that was
like they were some of our most few
videos that was on like our old channel
before then so it's not even anymore but
they were like channel yeah well there
was actually a previous era channel that
I've taken down since then so that was
like all our learning ground so oh it's
funny because I even liked years off the
game came out people were still watching
that video still comment on it like
everyday like some of those episodes got
to like a few hundred thousand views
just because they was like they're
literally watching it like an anime as
all right cool but
BSS what happened then obviously that we
carry and walking through there so we
were through Forza horizon into launch
we did the Forza horizon TOC we worked
on a few other games like sometimes work
so we worked in their reading
headquarters and then they'd like as
well as the Titans they were working on
the UK they sometimes bring in titles
they were sort of tested from the US so
we do some testing on Halo 4 org is
about judge movies and then a few other
games like that so then and then when it
came to Xbox one launch
there was you familiar with the upload
video platform on Xbox
the Lord dizzy who will not upload
creator oh geez that's not the thing so
we so then when hopefully came out they
are listen I could thing internally and
I applied for a different role in there
I moved to their London studio to be
associate when you thought upload and I
worked on upload like basically building
their creative program huge like they
can I saw a more initiate or doing my
community management slash back
production I used to like video stuff so
alright if you remember like the
official upload content they used to do
that I used to kind of be that star so
I'd like to some content
it was hella Vinci because that was also
like a turning point for the tunnel
because the first couple of years like
you know we kicked off the channel
because it was to six his idea again I
know it's like I haven't quite sort of
found a place that we were uploading
videos most off for fun but I wasn't
really sure fully through something I
wanted to do right I know is then when I
moved to upload and I started working
with them a lot as welcome we'd like the
camera crew there and obviously we were
doing videos I got I got a name drop
during that process did you get a chance
to meet like AC bungles any those guys
oh yeah I see one goes is the nicest guy
in there like he's his domain the best
person i xbox but he's so mean you
wonder like you know when you see him on
camera is out there like he is so
genuine what you see him three times and
I have to admit my impression is the
exact same he's like he seemed like a
really cool dude
he's so he's so cool oh yeah I got to
working on a few different projects and
stuff he was just like yeah just like so
much anything yourself you see he was a
great guy um yeah so that was obviously
that kind of way start to look at
through video there but it was
interesting cuz like during those first
couple years like I was super I don't
have the confidence on on like YouTube
and stuff so it's like a really weird I
think 500 feet so when I when I went to
work at upload and I worked with like
the camera crew and stuff they they all
really helped me like build confidence
on camera like learn to speak you know
like better on camera just saw like you
know no not to like look off and stuff
which was up here cuz it was really with
it was it was so like a first I used to
have to like set up the cameras and
leave the room because I just I just
wouldn't want to record with people
around yeah
I'd be I'd be like like yz250 wonder or
something I just know little paragraphs
and I just keep on messing up it's like
what the hell massively improved that's
all that kind of gave me actual
appreciation for all right you know what
I like do this because then suddenly an
upload I was make I was making some of
their videos and then I got home and
evening and make our videos so I was
just doing that all the time and then
that's where like the grind got super
serious because it's basically like cuz
I've only end up being you know I worked
more than I should have that I get in
the morning late I'll be in the office
until like nine ten and I and then I go
home and then I grind destiny videos why
I'm like yeah because that was that was
like that was really click try destiny
obviously we were like you know this is
we're gonna make it work I did that for
probably about 18 months so well cool I
Q know what Milo's different projects
their work we like those different
developers and obviously during that
time we helped build because we used to
like curate the front page so we would
like look at all the community content
we pick what we want to go on front page
we obviously engage the creators we took
some of them to things like III and
Gamescom and stuff so we ran all that
and obviously worked with different
companies like when the games were
launching so we did like campaigns
around like you know time for launch
destiny and things so yeah it was really
good and then but then when they kind of
make the switch and they kind of Windows
10 start being a big thing then the
American team when I want to say that
the ownership of like the platform so
they took upload cuz it was built in the
UK but they took off mode into there
like inside yeah and then but then when
they did that they had no need for the
content teams they were like you know
thanks Bob let's get the the order in
now when does so vg2 for seven calm was
during that period that was when we said
we left Microsoft obviously I made like
hello your friends they're like people I
knew that we did we did you two but we'd
have to kind of like you know do things
like outside of what we're doing at work
and stuff but we still did that so when
I left I basically sent out emails like
all my all the people that I knew is
like you know it's been great working
with you I'm leaving Microsoft but I am
gonna go and off and do my mention cuz a
basic attacks too sick so as I look you
know what
redundant I will use this one year I
don't know a year I'm gonna try I met
you to work like I'm gonna at all
I'm gonna and I'm gonna try and do this
for him for a year it works cool if it
doesn't I'm gonna have to go and find
myself a job and then luckily we managed
to like turn it around so obviously yeah
when we left I you know we we reached I
reached out everyone I was like yeah
this is what would I go and do so I'll
be great to like you don't work with
some of you guys and so that was it was
super useful because I'm so glad I did
it that way as well because like working
in the games industry gave me such a
great insight into like the way things
work and also like how to you know
properly work with publishers like if I
were a games coming out and I want to go
to them by I know how to properly work
with them be like you know I know what
you guys want I know I want you know
here's how we can work together things
like that so so yeah I mean it really
helped you use like Oh hundred million
views and listen I really appreciate all
that grind all that stuff that you were
saying it really showed inside all your
videos I really appreciated the grind a
lot of these you know the people that
are watching maybe they don't really
understand you see I really have VG 24
still on my phone like I really go
through and I still have I subscribed
you guys probably one of your earliest
subscribers and I keep that content
there because that's the genesis of my
information like me never going to
something I posted I send it to Cognito
I'm like this and it is yeah remember
yeah the hard work that you put in
translate it and they trickle down to me
because you said stuff that made me
understand it that's tough because a lot
of videos that I was watching with other
content creators they were saying stuff
that was like a but they were speaking
Chinese to meet me honest I really
didn't understand it but then you will
break it down and you'll show the damage
difference from one up low like let's
say they buff those the shotguns are
they both the auto
you show the damage difference between
different sides and I was like okay so
this how it was before this is how much
damage you're doing now he's very very
Lorax is very meticulous that's why I
like his stat like it's a very he
approaches it as if you he doesn't
assume that the person that's watching
knows about the content or the game and
not you have a great style in that sense
you don't saying like I really thank you
that especially with Destin because in
the beginning you know for someone
completely new to that kind of genre
there was something there kind of
overwhelming with the whole light level
chase and like you're very good with
beginner guys I think like you're a
master at that you really break it down
okay this which need to be doing this
the most effective way kind of like what
Lord King is saying is showing you the
difference yeah that's really cool yeah
because it's all the way that we always
want to try and present it I want to
make sure that like we try we try our
best to make sure our content can like
be useful to the people that are
hardcore but also like if you'd never
played before like you can be darker and
I think also like we kind of we've
always made content the way that we like
to consume it like I generally speaking
prefer short videos obviously there's
that interesting time in YouTube like
we're kind of people made this
transition to long-form content but like
generally speaking like I prefer to be
like you want to know something I want
to know like in two minutes okay like I
mean like I just and they slip sheets
down so you know it's no disrespect to
anyone that makes longer videos but for
me personally like I a to now very
quickly a lot of things like I just
notice it and be like sorry wait what
did you say it's good because let let's
be honest like the attention span of the
youth shout out low Derek you know
absolutely so that's so then like I said
you took those contexts and everything
from there and then you can even guys
yeah so it's a we yeah so when we left
them know kind of we watch that we saw
like work with Beast run 24/7 so we kind
of go in touch with them we like look
you know we where this is this the kind
of the content we do because we reach a
certain issue we like oh we do have a
lot of destiny content you know and they
were like we're actually you know kind
of works out well because we thought we
like one of the big on destiny and we
saw like these ones are kind of for that
voice so they're actually part of our
networks
a YouTube network or like gamer Network
who you know they cover challenge you
like challenge would have heard from
things like outside Xbox I said extra
where else is there to get like the
whole network involved yeah yeah so yes
it so they part of that once obviously
because you Pacey became so like under
the wing but then obviously we were to
VG on like testing stuff so if we were
making content stuff they wouldn't then
like Gospels and what we were doing so
like how it worked out while we started
with them predominately on destiny like
because we cover so many things and then
we effectively work with them on like
where you know wherever oh yeah they
they're like we don't solve like in the
in decide specifically smaller site we
have the kind of contact with them and
they just like nice or how are you know
they they run when they run their stuff
or they run their articles to then
they'll also do supporting stuff to like
our videos so I was like yeah do that
knack connectors Union because like I
said that's how I do you didn't like
even when you transition the division
like whatever would come up and I would
see it there would be like at the top
lesson like you know check out
Erickson's and I'm like okay there is
video embedded I'm like nice I get it
right in the article like it was so
convenient and I just said okay I'm
going you know to you channel there
because I've really that those destiny
one days definitely stand out big family
even when King betrayed us for the
division sound like it was the second
coming and my problem was the dark zone
and it was I remember that one video
because it was like if you have a
problem with the dog zone let me show
you how you can run it as or go alone
get this and you put this with this the
strikers gifts and I put this gets it
together and so for dudes ran down on me
I'll never forget not throw I'm a little
turret and it was flaming them and I was
I was hearing them up and I started
chasing people down is the truth and I
became a dog's own warrior solar lake
where you add I'm a mama Oh
you're tremendous tremendously
I like these stories this is good to see
where you know people started know that
good stuff so every guest we have to ask
this question on our back if you want to
seem to go well you have more please so
then interesting the Apple like when I
left Microsoft so I I went for six
months on the channel and then to she
was still at Microsoft seems to because
at that time he was working on Forza
horizon 2 so he like he wasn't at the
game launched off and then he was like
yeah you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
make this jump now so then he left and
that's when we both went full-time and
that's when we both had work on the
channel and then there was obviously
like there was kind of there was a
period for the first year where 2ct was
trying us off we were trying to do
something behind the scenes or like
making games either mobile games
something so he was like cuz he's a
programmer to sexism yes so he won't
like super hard on that but obviously
like this point where at the end of the
first year we're like you know what
we've invested money into it but it's
kind of one of those things where it's
like how long's a piece of string like
how much do you really to invest to get
this thing going we're like maybe isn't
the right time so that point he didn't
switch over to start streaming and then
obviously then he kind of picked up on
that and then he yes so like while we
all work on the channel Mustapha I
predominately do the videos we'll all
shout that like stuff like that Monday
and be like you know here's what we do
for the week but like I'll be welcome
videos he streams and then more recently
we then bought been on or paradise like
paradise central see if you see like to
see extreme emo Santi wishes paradise so
he's now kind of on board with the
channel as well and he kind of helps
with a contest I saw likes kind of
growing out oh yes sir you do tremendous
history well you gotta come out with a
book I want I want to see the early
Oh Oh before we I know but I hate when
people do this but you know like if you
go on the channel and you go and you
sort my oldest video first you can see
some things where you want to go if you
want to go down like some crazy history
then feel free to check him out but he's
loki in the side like I'm bleedin
everybody started but my channel started
in the destiny day now I know my early
videos with addict oh man
yeah good then we moved on we got a
little bit we improved but of yeah
that's history so I gotta ask this
question for all the guests of you have
at the roundtable Lord Eric's I need the
top five video games or video game
franchises so you what's your personal
faith let's go number one
Zota number 2 to me Monster Hunter Smash
Brothers okay uh before us probably be
Pokemon for me okay
Nintendo is strong in him like that
all-time gotta make the tough choice hmm
tough one I know it's not easy it's we
hi this is okay I always feel like
because it's not like a serious person
it's like you know one big game that
never stops to like a huge party like
what a walk-off like back in the days I
wouldn't win who was that like that
wasn't me that was huge universe to you
I just paid too many hours on that and
that was a yeah I think I think off the
top of the spot I mean that's probably
either one that I think I mean like but
yeah definitely so at least those top
three top Thor
so that's your top five right Didion's
Elda the Pokemon master hunter world
World of Warcraft
mm that's what we goin with ya second is
that what I want to be branded kind of a
while ago up and twisted I saw like the
main aim your top serious stuff and
you'll always write it and as soon as
you finished writing it you put you hit
Send like I'm probably going to look
back on this Malik
why do not say this but I definitely at
least at least at least year number one
I yes Zoda
Monsanto Bruce Pokemon and then five is
like in flux though that five is in flux
but for now with his world Warcraft
falling down red is history man love it
love it love it so let's get into what
the Lord's have been playing this week
and uh actually just go back to Eric's
again what do you mean quite
specifically just because it's been all
Master Hunter this week um actually no
not to my knowledge is all in between
like events stuff like I'm playing it a
little bit slightly more lightly so I'm
kind of jumping in for videos and stuff
so I actually jumped on I was like our
boys are they okay that's kind of a
while ago but like I I wanted to play I
was kind of following but I sort of left
at the time and they came our switch so
played um placed on a pimp a bit marry
tennis as well because it recently came
out yeah people tell me that's deep we
got a talk you got a talk because that
blooper is taking my it's funny because
I'm not really a sports person but like
when it's like a merrier twist I'm like
you know what I got time for this mm
shut up the Lord foggy foggy said last
week he was playing tennis and he said
it was like very complex like it was
like it's a lot of depth to this game
there is yeah it's funny cuz you saw
like you think like tennis and Mary's
it's well it's also funny cuz when you
kind of get those games that are like so
light hearts on the surface it makes it
even funnier like more competitive when
you're playing on people like if you
lose a game area today if you use that
nobody gets any serious business
[Laughter]
have a blast blue cross tag battle I
kind of get my words but I was trying to
play though their Lord addict what have
you implying speak man um
XCOM thanks go to more XCOM and just was
more ex-con Florence you got those
chosen kilt yet you got that you know I
killed all three of those chosen dice I
kill one with a padding it just shot the
chose that he killed him like it's yes
disrespectful I saw you put it up on
upload I laugh when I finally got a
chance to see it this morning I couldn't
believe you did that to one of the
chosen I was happy I was panicking for a
second but when I saw he did a crit for
24 I was like that's what's up that's a
soda it's called life Lord solve what
has it been has been all tennis would
you be blaming homespun switch to a lot
of tennis and like I'm I'm halfway
through that story mode and there's a
there's a boss on a boat it's a blooper
right um yeah he's destroying me like
he's really really destroying me this
dude should be like the end boss because
like he gets all over the court with no
problem and then he has these he has
trick shots where this particular stage
has your on your arms like in an olive
on a ship right so you have like the
mass right in the middle of the ship so
you can bounce balls off the middle of
this pole so this dude takes every
opportunity to direct balls awesome
there have been I've gotten close to
beating him like five six times but
other times he's just raking me over the
coals like destruction all the way
through so yeah I'm playing that and I
got luminous remastered I never played
luminous oh yeah I'm more for like
old-school Tetris but I do like lumen
this is cool I never played it on PSP
back in the day so I didn't really know
what to expect but 15 bucks great game
though good puzzle the music musicality
of that game it definitely takes it to
another level no doubt more King would
you implant it Oh
destiny shout-out to my trial it's much
yo I got these to trial hugs right so I
got home
oh my god I got Chris I got Chris and
Captain America right yo and Captain
America's tactical I don't know if y'all
ever see me play with these two guys if
I get these two guys both in one room at
one time it is the most amazing
experience that I can have with destiny
at one time and I did it this week with
a nightfall we finished that nightfall
in 14 minutes
I'm talking about these two tripods it's
always a measuring contest when they get
inside the room I'm like it is just the
most amazing thing ever to watch these
two guys go at it and I said Y also have
a channel it should be y'all two only in
the channel like cuz they're looking at
each others clothes I just want to tell
you guys it's one game that I got from
Lauren outdoor mom it's a salt android
cactus
it's free on Microsoft for for gold this
month get that game okay it is it is
probably the best game that I got from
from Rand he put me on it because I
spoke to him you know I send my message
because he put up a video that game is
worth is to get it for free it's
unimaginable but to pay for it I'll pay
for that game the game is worth every
last penny try it out stop the Lord ran
he's a beast man absolutely I never look
into it man yeah man for me I'm kind of
been with Lord King I've been on that a
destiny to catalyst grind faction rally
so I want to shout out some Lords real
quick demon and revolves the team l
kneel before God he goes up when it's a
shot at the Fonzarelli in a relevant
native resort getting little blades on
everybody trying to do their little
catalyst ground or what-have-you
so it's all about dead orbit right now
I'm sorry heard Dale from new monarchy I
need that graviton Lance that oh man a
hidden hand I need that perk so I'm at
level 45 I'm five away from the grind to
be done and I touched a little bit of
state he became two with the
Independence Day pack
downloaded that and I watch I didn't get
a chance for plagues I've already played
it already but I had to
get on inside remember inside oh yeah
love that game the ambience the dudes
from play dead Studios man limbo
creators absolutely love that so what we
gonna get into this hole so last week's
poll results have come through and the
people have spoken to the question with
the Rican recent acquisition of five
gaming studios underneath the marks of
studios umbrella-like
under labs ninja tearing etc is it too
early to tell if these acquisitions were
smart business move the winner at 49% in
a threeway poll is the no it is not too
early these moves were smart for the
future of Xbox coming in at 28% in
highly contested 20% was yes it is too
early the games must show improve first
and coming in at a razor clear place
razor close at 23% was Phil Spencer has
the studio Infinity Gauntlet group this
poll I think I mean I think I think it's
definitely a sensible move cuz I mean
one but one of the things obviously we
still need to see what those studios
will kick out right it's one thing you
solve like name check oh yeah we've got
all these guys you still need to do or
they gonna choice but seeing the stuff
that they have done in the past and
knowing that like Microsoft is an
interesting place we turn a spoken--
unlike earlier how goes all that time
back around 360 like during the ps3
quiet period we're like next books like
super dominant right from there and then
it seems to have shifted like right now
that ps4 is just killing it right now I
feel like the phone yeah I mean III love
my xbox right you know I used to be used
to be the console was on pretty much all
the time and like now I don't play as
much I don't even turn it on though I've
done my job the other day when I turned
it off that's how kind of like wow yeah
yeah the crazy thing you later they've
always if you look I look at them like
Microsoft's always had this this sort
strange mentality where it's like
alright you know as long as we've got
Forza gears and Halo with fine like it's
like you say you know what they're good
games but you can't hold on to just
those three forever like people are
gonna get forward and
I mean already like I mean I I don't
mind like I don't mind some of that's
before three halos but I know that
people like still people aren't like
halos not kind of do what people
wouldn't see right now
give us a war like you know I enjoyed
the last most fun to play through but
it's still like crime anymore like for
like you know for suppose though right
it's great if you like Forza but I don't
really feel that forces the system
cellar like you'd feel like if that's it
they need to have an obviously like you
know they might not a few first bike
studios today got rare that we've kind
of like see a thief I'm so glad they put
it out because obviously you know it's
nice to see the work on you I hear might
not necessarily be like track in the
same way they wanted to right now
hopefully but they just need they need
more stuff and they can kind of say is
there's right anime are some solid
Studios I mean ninja theory of done some
amazing stuff oh hell blade bro exactly
where I mean that now is incredible
something else nothing thumbs more so if
they can use that to solve like bolster
their sore suppose they like they saw
like first party lineup then I think
it's great though because they they need
to do it and they might be in a position
where they're thinking all right you
know what we hope we don't might not
necessarily have any like studios that
we own that can kind of fill this void
so let's just bring some people in and
then so I mean yeah so so business-wise
it makes sense but yeah it's true that
we do need to see that like now they've
been acquired what are they actually
gonna work on cuz it's you know if we if
it gets the point where like next e3
they're like oh yeah by the way all
these names we've acquired
we still got them we haven't gotten in
the show but we still got agree lordy
box is entering the realm are you there
sir what is going on the nightfall
soloist and monster hunter in the build
oh man this is gonna be crazy
are you baby I'm doing good just
listening watching one of the guys the
let me led me to do what I do as well so
air a two man frozen content been
watching you for a long time like me my
little solo nightfall videos that I do
nothing compared to what you do I have
making videos absolutely but shut up you
bugs jumping through man so this is a
good way you jumped in for advantage
because we got Eric's in the building
and we gonna talk about the battle
coming into 2019 you go get it to these
topics there's a and a battle coming in
2019 of the share world shooter
we've got deaths
- we've got anthem and the division -
entering the realm next year so I want
to bring this off the Lord Eric's in the
sense that okay
what are you who you think some box in
2019 it's kind of start with the
strengths and weaknesses you know what
you see from each you know each game so
I'm gonna bring it to you what do you
think about the battle coming in Oh
first the other need to hire some people
to play some games for me because I'm
not gonna have enough time I feel like
so I felt destiny is thoughts well
already because like even though that's
new right now it might like you
- already be everyone's favorite topic
the point is like it's it's it's quite
well because of the interesting thing
about the placement for that is that
like there'll be forsaking will come out
in December and then September and
they'll be will come out in December
right they'll be like that next
expansion because they've got one of
those ones listed for 2018 right so
they'll they'll drop in December and
then it probably won't be like till
either end of March or April if I
sensible will be April right all right
in kind of in solving their way they can
always skip that window they can kind of
come before we forsake incumbent off
always some DLC and then where their
game is winding down a little bit um and
they should use is they should use this
as like a sensible thing they should be
like alright you know what people are
gonna go for a free months and go jump
into division jump into anthem we can
use this time to work on what's next so
hopefully they're sensible with that and
they drop the next thing I really know
around my April May something like that
so that's making almost almost sort of
skip the heavy competitive window right
it is true that obviously for a lot of
people that have stepped away from
destiny and it's like why am i coming
backs destiny negative me they only
gravitate more towards things like
division and anthem because they gonna
be like this looks like the new hot
thing but at least for the people that
like play destined you do want to sort
of dip in and out I feel like destiny is
kind of position quite well um division
of destiny division anthem they the ones
going head-to-head this the interesting
things so division has the advantage
that are like it's it's already
established to a certain degree
there's two sides to again there are
there's obviously division went through
like a rocky road you started out really
solid went kind of downhill for a bit
then they've since brawler back and like
where the game is that like right now is
a really good position it all mostly saw
yeah it's always that what we saw with
um destiny one right like they ended yes
in a race olive
so all the kind of like or Division fans
like you know what yeah we're super
ready for it they've seen division to e3
they're really excited for it like a lot
of people that stepped away from it I
like I'm looking forward to coming back
you know I've been doing a few videos of
people like are you I'm looking for like
a touchdown back in so because that's
already a like a known and the things
that they they've been quite clever
about the way they've message it they've
been like oh the the stuff that we know
was a problem the first time we're going
big on this they've already said like we
built the game with em game first and
then we've gone backwards oh yeah and
then a play a raise man I couldn't
believe that exactly what I say yeah so
so I mean that that's a massive thing
right that's some of the people asking
for a like a long time so made up a name
check that stuff and be like you know
what our sequel has this right so that
means if you're if you're consuming
you're like all right I've got one game
here which I know what it's all about I
know what I'm gonna get out of it and
while it'll be like new experiences I
still I can picture it and then you got
anthem right which is like super
exciting that HOTAS play it like really
really cool but right now there's still
a lot of questions right like yeah I
mean you know and again we're we're
quite away from launch so that doesn't
worry me because the other day it's like
you know in the way that PR is the real
thing stuff we can find out plenty more
in that time but at least as it
currently stands like there's a lot of
things you don't know about anthem but
we it looks cool it plays cool the
surface level stuff is really really fun
but people that want to like you know
have someone dip into that sort of edge
onra we still don't know what it's gonna
keep us coming back to answer yeah back
and what would be how do you feel I
gonna ask you this now how do you feel
about no pvp at launch friend for me I
don't mind cuz I'm not really a PvP guy
right like I like ìokay PvP like you
know sometimes I play we like with
friends and stuff and like I can jump in
I can you know semi hold my own but I'm
not like a top tier PvP player
PvE is what I do right it's always been
that way you are like most times so much
and even like I missed on the dark zone
but I still be PvE zwarst mi cyant so I
don't really bother you and does it
affect you no I feel like a kind of a
neatly spirits they turn off the light
if they can if they can provide like an
amazing world would like lows and like
really cool activities plenty of talent
they've ridden to come back and I don't
think you'll necessarily be a problem
because they haven't like discounted
that it can be a thing they're just
saying is not launching with it right
and if anything it kind of makes a
there's a brand new IP if they can focus
their efforts on making like a super
solid
you know PvE experienced and then later
on they can look at like adding
something in that make sense maybe maybe
because obviously there's also the
challenges I'm sure they've seen like
you know challenges when you kind of
have these kind of games trying to
balance PvE and PvP and the way that
kind of works so maybe it's something
that maybe it's a battle they don't want
to have maybe the totally more in
districts like you Bioware very good at
like single-player and narratives no
yeah absolutely I mean they realize that
PVE pvp might like and also makes it
like I would rather they launch with a
solid PvE and then PvE and like a really
bad PD no absolutely absolutely you rat
you don't want any type of yeah you
don't want to mess or broken product I
rather than take day time with if it's
if it's not ready
so I understandable you understand we're
gonna swing back around here at the end
of this topic that we get I needed the
hard and fast protection later let you
take out it Lord eat bonta's mean you
have had this discussion oh wait we we
talked about it during the Dark Ages of
Nestle to lunch and I'm very curious now
things are kind of like panning
themselves out destiny to is kind of
maybe you're not spec so some and then
you got anthem that people are very
excited about and obviously division
like Lord Eric said I mean it's just
been so much improved and they look like
they're ready for war that they learn
from their mistakes so what do you guys
when you feeling about these games no I
mean Eric said it pretty well already I
think the fact that I just put it in
chat to don't be a jack-of-all-trades
kind of the way destiny is trying to be
PvE and PvP don't and they can't figure
out a way to balance both because if you
have a game like anthem and I just got
done listening to something else about
another game if you have those tears we
can get weapons that are almost broken
in a PvP setting you don't worry about
breaking PvP if PE you need this elite
thing that you can go for and strive for
and have those upper echelon pieces that
wouldn't break a PvP thing but you're
not worried about that because you want
another story and a solo effort and
things like that so I mean anthem has
potential to do that I think division is
an amazing place and I think destiny has
a chance I um I was gonna say I couldn't
the phrase do you better I think you say
it's gonna miss it I think that's
actually right it's gonna do it
september big launch it's gonna have its
December release
and then the two after that potentially
will or won't so you all have either one
your people back or not so I've got a
coconut snow there's one cook you and
Eric to break up a good point an
interesting point about destiny missing
that window right with that well those
guys kind of go head to head next year
don't you think are you not concerned
that um that may hurt destiny because
the playerbase now if these games are
good because kind of happened when
division first came out I want to visit
came out strong and everybody making
fighting every week my witness they was
like destiny is dead we're done with
this game listen in all essence
I prefer how the flow of division goes
this is just my preferred be very
grounded yeah it's very grounded so I
liked it like when when Lord addict was
saying that if they were spongy I say
okay um if they have on armor and they
hiding behind stuff I like that I like
that Tom Clancy feel and that's what it
brought to me so that was my only thing
is just I love um you know the destiny
for the halo feel okay like you know my
son says it the best he says yeah your
game is called destiny my game is called
halo like and it's because he sees the
traits from the companies and the way
the gun handles the way to gun sways the
way gun moves his destiny so I got my
destiny and it's halo and it's it's all
wrapped up in someone that's fun but
when I'm gonna get grounded I'm gonna
get grounded in this place shut up now
though he said the only reason why you
like the video cuz you a New Yorker and
they did New York
it look like DC so they know how to do
of their locations very well New York
was done perfectly like a place where I
got a hot dog from so I'm just jumping
in there real quick
I will throw anthem in the bushes
because I don't need an Iron Man
simulator so those two games will always
Duke it out because that's how they
start a the Titans of it we have an
unknown variable and antler and right
yeah but yeah and they establish - I
honestly believe the fight balls down to
these two Titans hmm so you would knock
an anthem out you think it's division in
in destiny I'm knocking it out because
this is a simple fact these two have got
they lumps already right they'd already
been knocked down by each other and they
went back any fixed things I played
destinies to forsaken czar gambit mode
I'm telling you that thing is crack good
yeah so now you have the division and I
play the division - when I saw the video
and Microsoft showed us that the game
don't look like that that's bull when I
got a chance to play it that night it's
exactly what they were showing oh this
is for real they took their lumps this
is round 2 in a giant fight you got this
up-and-coming fighter and he doesn't
have the foot movement or the hands beat
as these other dudes and he's gonna get
knocked out in round 1 and he's coming
from EA so - kid what you gotta get
sovereign in so avanti's you did
interrupt you on that point so you know
about that window yeah
who's gonna so part of what destiny does
is it releases September biggest influx
of destiny players is always gonna be a
major release same is taking Kings same
every September release is gonna be its
biggest piece now the smaller expansions
are gonna be you know if you got the
annual pass you staying around things
like that some people will some people
won't so September before and then
September and 2019 it's got enough space
also don't forget Red Dead Redemption
and end of October that's a factor you
can't forget either that basically could
wait for a while if Rockstar pulls a GTA
online or something like that I mean I
think about that so but I think in
general I think Kings got a good point
anthem is an unknown we don't know but
also my worry about anthem is how much
in-game can there be divisions within
game and that's one thing that took them
a little while to figure out they're
stressing it for round two destiny has
raids which are great but it's like you
know depending on the grind of things if
anthem is only PvE only and without the
PvP factor just to have a balance of
something else to do what if you do get
to that max and you have everything come
with a true game at ninety in a chat
said he is like without PvP he said his
dad I think I think it'll be like
destiny we have it's good release I
think it'll have an awesome December I'm
gonna definitely try a Division two as
well and I want to try both but as Eric
said I need copies of me to try and play
all these games cuz I never have enough
yeah seriously there's not enough of me
to go around to play anything I finally
stepped away stopped recording and I
played God of War and Detroit and it was
fun to just sit down and play a game for
just me because I don't do that that
often so I miss those moments but man
March is gonna be a rough but I think I
think the other two Davitt I mean anthem
has coolness I just don't know how long
it'll last
I still think it's the other two gosh
you lord addict I'm curious uh I think
it's gonna be between I don't for some
reason I want this I'm wanting to put
anthem in the fight but I don't I don't
think anthems gonna I think what you
know I'm a pvp person I like it and the
moment they told me there's not a PvP in
it I was just like I don't know how I
feel about the acid the same thing about
the division and the division had
hard time going because it didn't have
PvP like regardless if you're a PvE
person or PvP person everyone can agree
that once the PvE person have vacated
the property because they ain't nothing
to do PvE why's the people that are
keeping those servers up is PvP playing
the trials playing the the the nine
playing all that those are the people
coming back that the glory is probably
trials urged pvp like crazy on deck or
glory of ala crucible trials that we
know trials of Osiris and trials and I'm
a child's good as Osiris but we know
that during destiny ones dark ages like
you said Lord addict you know that
trials definitely kept the community
going so I would agree I would agree
with that man and I just feel like I
know why and I don't know see and I feel
like people my bit my issue with these
kind of games is people don't see it as
an anthem people don't see the division
they always refer to this is the destiny
killer ever it's like these games stand
on their own they have to be the destiny
killers and I see people like y-you know
I like the game play us all but I just
want to make sure it has a great store
and like you're not gonna get that on
the first package you get like these
games aren't designed doing all the
story in one experience like they're
designed to do them for years to come
and people have the wrong and people
like what it's Bioware they'll do it but
we can't change the way these games are
made yes it is to go ahead did you teach
it he said you got too much it be the
PvE out of control anyway moving on look
good sovereign the master of look in
this big man what helps that I don't
play them that much is that I can look
at it very much two hours there like
every day have to give a baby I was in a
fire you have a unique takes how would
you take on this my thinking is this I
think
what destiny too is done were forsaken
and what Division two is doing is that
they're acknowledging that they made the
mistake of not catering to the hardcore
from the jump they have to do that so my
thinking is that I don't I don't
eliminate anthem from the equation
because my thinking is by Wars looking
at this you're not gonna put in
you're not gonna add another shared
world shooter into the mix without
looking at the mistakes of other games
in that genre and trying to rectify them
so my thinking is that regardless of the
fact there's no PvP mm-hmm got the grind
during PvE is gonna be something that
hardcore fans of Destiny and division
are gonna be drawn to destiny division
or mana hunter so my thing is I think
they I think they're coming ready with
that know how much of it there is I
don't know and obviously and and how how
they integrate that into story to make
it interesting for people to do like
like Destiny's doing now mom is gonna be
interesting how they do but to me I
think that by the time these two games
come out destiny has to be in a place
where the hardcore are back facts facts
if not Destiny's done if destiny is not
giving people in September exactly what
they've always wanted from destiny and
an evolution from what they were doing
in destiny one mm-hmm
have problems because regardless to what
again Division two is gonna be bringing
new things to the table and them like I
said I think they're gonna be ready for
that I think I I think that the overlap
and the people were gonna want to play
all three of these games is gonna is
huge to me
but I just think that a destiny destiny
is do is is like the is the point where
everything kind of jumps off from right
if destiny is not where it needs to be
it's done I think no doubt no doubt all
right I'm gonna bring it back to you I'm
Eric's as well finish this thing off gun
to your head Lord Eric's yeah I know
it's early
I know I know more information has you
know it's gonna come out you know we
don't know what everything is gonna do
out of these three well your Eric's if a
gunny ahead at the end of 2019 who do
you think stands
hello so here's a missing thing as well
I one of the one of the things I've been
think he's slightly more recently like
as we saw hearing more self anthem as
well is that is it's also while it
exists in a very similar space there's
also a kind of chance that it might
exist in a slight in a slightly
different space right so like here's the
things I destiny in division are all
intensive purposes very very similar
right anthem based on what we know so
far
obviously we they say you know I had to
interview Tron and water and stuff and
he said that you know this there's gonna
be soft with a weekly basis there's
gonna be reason to come back there's
gonna be things that those or signature
things that basically make it again the
fits in this space well the same time
obviously you know with with Bioware
strengths being like story well I think
one of the two big things that these two
games lack like division and destiny is
obviously like really good way to tell
the story about this this story and
destiny we need to go digging for it
right this story in division we need to
go digging for it like I feel like it's
almost like the anthem could stand a
chance to slay to basically bring story
and proper stories having in turn
disappointed they got Casey Hudson - yes
there's there's a chance they could do
something that the other two have never
done before right and then when I think
about this this way I was thinking
myself the other day alright so what if
there's a chance that they're being
slightly vague about endgame because
maybe they don't have the same endgame
any other people do
I'm will I'm like if I look at the whole
experience I could still see him as a
game that like I would jump in Oh play a
playlist enjoy the story I would level
for javelin and if I came to like an end
off to say like 100 hours I'd be like
you know what it's kind of cool right
because I've had a good experience maybe
it doesn't be the game that maybe it's
necessary within that kind of you come
back to all the time but if they then
release like content updates or like
chunks or something it could be one of
those games that maybe you complete you
kind of like quote-unquote complete to a
certain degree and you kind of go and
like a little break and then you kind of
come back so maybe is a game you
check-in out almost like what most
answers kind of doing with like these
monthly releases so maybe maybe they
actually end up targeting a similar
genre but a slightly different space
which would therefore allow them to
exist alongside these things because
then if they imagine if it got to the
point where you did you add some stuff
like you kind of came back and you felt
like you've done everything and then you
could pause we're gonna play guessing
your division anything comes out you
know let me check back in for anthem cuz
something's happening right so is the
chance that they might be doing
being a little bit different uh because
of that difference you thinking that
they can then coexist in that space they
won't be direct okay this is based on
right the way that they spoken the stuff
first off right now like it could be
that you know if you like to a few miles
time they just come on they're like
here's our end game plan and actually
lines perfectly up with destiny there
maybe there than the mummy different
story but I'm kind of going based on the
way we know of it right now it's also
important to realize the like there's
yeah obviously there's that it's kind of
like the the people online the you know
they'll they've already written it off
because there's this association with
the a right like I kind of said before
that you know I I go into everything
like for me I go into everything with
like a super open mind like you can say
to me like why you still playing destiny
I'm like you know what I see every
expansions a chance to do something
right because obviously having worked in
the industry I know things I I know
sometimes things going wrong on wrong
ways in your control and sometimes you
can try your best to fix you right so
like I realize that you know like
despite what people were saying Bungie
on out there trying to just like put the
hand of your pocket still your money I
don't know what the reasons are but I'm
telling ya they're know developers to
steal your money
some people low-key like try to like
psychologically manipulate you and as
many money it's definitely true there
are some practices that obviously do
encourage that kind of approach to soft
in the end and at the other day is till
the business rights like this need to
make money so like the other day is some
of them on the best practices but the
point is right there are people out
there that I've already written off the
game they don't know about just because
they see the EA simple rhyme like that
to me is like a you know so you need to
see everything as a separate you know
that's why I'm gonna go into it with
that - anyway so yeah I I feel like
there's a good chance there could exist
alongside than based on what we've heard
so far and then yeah it will sort be a
dukale between like destiny and division
but again because of their release time
it's almost like when destiny like slows
down divisional speed up and then
divisional obviously here a part time
rate slows down that's probably when the
destiny of they all come out and
hopefully if that works they can
actually almost end up coexisting in the
sense that question lord out good
I'm putting pressure on you I know you
cover these games I know you like these
games and we all love though it is just
a fun thing is that like you know your
gut feeling we think stands tall as the
definitive gate a game that holds the
player base the game that kind of you
know retains throughout 2019 I'm not a
mess of sponsorships anything what you
know right okay what you know right
arise the division because division like
it comes out an entire year of free
content mmm no questions asked that's
true you can't you can like even if the
game goes badly you can still come back
and you'd have to pay a penny and you're
there for a year mmm that's huge
and then the Ubisoft thing Ubisoft over
the past few games they've showed that
they have a dedication to the games like
No so I got you I got I got I got Eric's
ass off with the visual eatery by team
it's the steady I'm gonna chair um
that's all with you call you Dublin them
yeah I'm doubling down I would say okay
we got to it division
lordy Bart is dead let's get a look at
it I just get a dick max I hate
troubling to be I'm gonna say right now
we don't know what Division two is gonna
bring us as of right now to me is kind
of dead from here till September at
least I don't know what September is
gonna bring us
I could tell me all they want but then
they can literally show me like oh
here's that here's the gold candies and
then when you get it it's like but
they're rotting on the bottom but
they're going on the top you know you at
that point you don't trust them
just like I was so disgusted with the
raid layer but I got and see the raid so
yeah so right now your destiny Trust is
not there and you're a hike for division
you you were the one that did message me
for when I when I was at e3 and you say
yo division got raids and whatever
whatever then that ant my never heard
you really talk about so you you got a I
just I'm saying anthem because first off
it's gonna come out after all these
games will probably be off their peak
you said 2019 yeah by the end of 2009
Titan II the game people have been
playing the most at that time is gonna
be handsome I mean you know the division
is probably going to come out to
beginning what doesn't at the beginning
of 2019 or my dates off time Erik's you
might be the helping February 22nd isn't
it like it doesn't come out that day
that everything comes out I think so
there's a murderer's row day with like 4
days yeah my money March is you know you
got that time between Mars March 15
you got that petanque okay by the time
between March who see when a game first
debuts especially anthem it's going off
a Bioware going off that uh you know the
ages of the age games going off of uh
you know the Mass Effect games people
expect a huge story Adam we don't know
if that's gonna happen you see the
there's on that the cut you chad is
saying division more 15 and 20 say
anthem is the one that's coming out on
those multiple game release date so
that's that's the one so I'm sorry
continuing I just think I think after
man like you know to me it's gonna be
the divinity it's to me it's gonna be
destiny but I think anthems gonna get a
better reception next year something as
well just because it's the new thing
that I think it people want to succeed
and like Eric said like they have an
opportunity to come in and elevate the
shared world shooter we right we know
with a different approach to
storytelling maybe a different approach
right like something to give that's a
lot of
see say that anthem looks like the game
they wanted the destiny to be I do see
that coming a lot for the narrative guys
yeah I do I could swear anta came out
both after but you know it's so far it's
still I'm still holding that like people
are going to gravitate towards the newer
stuff than the stuff that's been
rehashed gotcha
and especially what the the kind of
feeling that the game has when you see a
guy I've been the first person to be
like I don't know about anthem but
there's a lot of hype behind this game
especially they focus on entirely PvE
and they give you like like the
definitive edition of raids and stuff
because they're only focusing on stuff
like that like I might go to anthem it
there's like fire raids it like moving
on steroids because that's not their
doing is those okay think they've
announced any Connery Lord eat boxes I
need you babe what's good please set the
record straight
hello is that let me die by issues like
biased because we literally do eight to
hour-long discussion so here's my piece
let's go destiny I think we're gonna
know fairly early on from forsaken it's
gonna make it that far so if it doesn't
well I really like low chance because
year six of destiny would be September
than you have height before end of 2019
so you would have another year of what
is the ticket would you guys say it's a
fair assumption to say if they drop the
ball forsaken they're in a bad place I
love that game every time I play it I
enjoy it but I'll just like they can't
they cannot drop the ball for sake and
they need to hit that ball out of the
park
I think Eric's had a pretty a really
good point that anthem could be
something different because
the PvE the PvP it's really a Loutre
shooter to a point what a thing it
leaned a little more into a Bioware RPG
story element situation I would love to
see that have a separate piece where you
could even bounce between one or two of
them if your divot as the or division
you could also be one of those and
anthem have a way to I think it's kind
of worth considering as well they're
like on initial sales I reckon like
anthem will be the big one out the door
because we know people online they're
kind of they're all like share their
voice by you know say I think they will
they do and they don't like ultimately
that's vocal minority right so that's
why they're the kind of casual audience
though ones let's all board st2 and they
want and them like having sauces plays
like those know people there they will
buy anthem krysta them anthem is the new
thing the shiny thing really looks
pretty cool they're gonna buy it right
whereas to them they've seen division
before they've seen dusty before so oh
boy you should appeal anthem is gonna
smash out the park right but we see of
course so I wish with whether it you
know by the end of 2019 is still one of
people are playing you know that might
still be different unless we hear people
are gonna refer this is it's that game
with the iron man see fit easy buzz I
mean that pretty much is in it's like
I'm it's like I love destiny I like all
three of these games the leveling up and
one to 30 and division was amazing like
the endgame raids and destiny are
awesome
if anthem has its separate piece from
that there's just enough of me that I
want to play all of them I wish there
was so my end of it was like I think
destiny is gonna know it's answered by
September if it doesn't hold through I
think anthems newness could honestly set
out okay the average player that plays
these genres will play two of these not
all three now more 10 gun to your head I
need them in thinking that this anthem
is gonna be the second coming of Diablo
it's shot so I anthems winning gotcha
you're gonna get a bunch of people like
you said the cat
you guys never get this game finishing
in 5 hours and throw it in the bush and
STD right in and I'm gonna tell you this
I mean the vision as much as I love you
as near and dear to my heart
Destiny's gonna smash this is why it's
gonna smash you in the mouth I played
that first bacon right and I've played
that PvP PvE aspect of it and jumping
through that portal there's nothing like
jumping through that portal red and
handling your business like you get your
I single-handedly wrecked out of a squad
like single-handedly has three rounds
that you had if they can make it to the
second round you're not making it to the
second round I squashed them and I got
them out it was showing my gameplay up
there because we do this destiny stuff
for real
know the fast aspect of the action in
destiny is a lot faster than division
where the cover based shooter right so
that's that sometimes off puts people
all right cover based shooter
methodically moving to flank them you
know that stuff is different all right
it slows down the pace and you can push
it faster if you try mm-hmm
destiny has that magic when done
correctly when you are stormcaller
and you're disappearing in between and
you're blowing up in a minute listen
they told you that their prisoner elders
you're gonna fill back up that president
all this type of thing they told you
that they fixing the rage if a champion
gets knocked down what does the champion
do this champion is coming and he's
bringing that spire all right you got
you have raids that you are dying for
listen they have they have the ace in
the hole if they ever say that they have
old ray like a crow to raid
we mastered like a molten glass do you
do you understand what it sounds like
when they say what the glass we mastered
like when in doubt they have a nuclear
weapon that they can drop it any time
and they notice and they're holding it
mm-hmm but I highly doubt they would
ever do that I don't I don't know I
won't
I won't put it past a losing champion
you can throw that haymaker and knock
you out cold how would you know King oh
and let me say one thing to you on this
and this is where you coming from
somebody who loves destiny they if they
have those aces in the hole and they're
really really feeling confident I don't
think they would have dropped the story
bomb they did at e3 that was a marketing
ploy and I wish they wouldn't have done
that because if I would have played eat
the story in destiny and one mission
wonderful happens yeah and see that
happens my mind would have been exploded
yeah so I wish that would have not been
shown and if they feel they had to do
that they feel they have to still push
so you know I actually really listen to
every flashpoint I actually watch every
flash alright and I want you to
understand lower pack needle is gonna
tell you I mean when I walked away from
destiny I walked away from destiny and I
was doing other things
I'm pub G to the death yeah listen to me
when I'm telling you that Forsaken is
coming and when it hits it's going to
hit and it's going to reverberate if you
look at the content on Xbox right now
destiny is number eight yeah that's with
my boards take the bed period yeah okay
eight on the most played games list on
Xbox Live I just hit a deal when it
drops it's gonna it's gonna hold weight
and you got these other games coming out
I don't want to take anything away from
anthem but I'm telling you you did it no
no I'm going to spray the bushes it has
three things going against it
da hmm all right that's that's one all
right all right so the confidence in ei
I have absolutely zero right not alone
though a lot of a lot of people fit in
the industry are ya at the moment right
all right
the whole PvP no BBB all right and then
how much content can you put in a one
player game without burning through what
he did say for I mean it's for player
drop in drop out I mean we did I mean
that's real cute but essentially
division to death to do same day yeah
but they do the same thing and they have
other stuff that can hold your time
we've infinite anthem we don't know as
of right now we just don't know it we
just drag this pulled it up and I'm
telling you destiny alright what hands
down hill is da Macbeth
all right I think everyone is on fire
right now
Erichs is on fire but everywhere even
addict I understand what's coming from
the way I look at it is you know the
strengths of each you know I'm saying
and I'll start with the least person who
I think I'm worried about anthem at one
stage I think that people if the king is
nailing a lot of points the thing I'm
worried about anthem y'all is the
release date it's after the check
because people acting like days gone
Exodus and these other games they all
drop and crap I know people laugh I
cracked them both for games dropping
that that release date that's insane and
we've all seen EA make tactical errors
and other pecans to release things the
titanfall to battlefield yagna got not
paying attention I don't move as of
right now if they stay on that date
that's a problem
in another day things that you have to
look at is this a multi-planet well that
day two exclusives from two different
from two different exist so it's like
they have to move that date but knowing
EI I'm concerned that they will stay
stubborn and they've already delayed the
game once already Eric's correct me if
I'm wrong right didn't add them already
get delayed once what they didn't
actually like officially announced a
date like they kind of announced like
they were so like a rough window I think
until they today officially announce
today and then push you back that
doesn't right delayed right so again
this is no disrespect of the game the
game looks great
eternally though I don't think maybe a
tournament yeah so it's like I and I
want the game to succeed like Casey
Hudson's my dude from Mass Effect like I
want this game succeed the foreplay look
bill shot a week me and on like I said
uh Sam tore that EA play we got a chance
to see I know Eric's you got a chance to
see that damn it look great I like the
verticality I like going under the water
the javelins look cool look shut up
Eric's watch his videos he's got great
videos on it on the Eric I mean the
javelins that we know so far so I'm
hoping I'm just worried about that
release show and no pvp like King said
that's the thing division for me as a
destiny fan is who I'm scared right I'm
nervous
they come in you not I mean like they
did that like like Lord Eric said like
they took everything the community said
they built it back up they even added a
dedicated PvP mode as well as dogs all
correct oh no am I wrong on that uh I
mean nobody's number one yeah right in
part one in part one so you know now
we're talking
eighth play of raids you're talking you
know all this stuff and everything raids
are a little bit overkill to be honest
true but elite hard time finding six
okay we got four we need two more
that's good be like okay we got four
we'd be four more I asked him forty
people have something you know another
four that you can do is pretty
impressive right they still got the dogs
on people love the dogs on and one thing
that the division does well shout out
the Lord High Basu is for the people who
love hard more hardcore MMO
sensibilities with mid maxing and gear
sets and watch them Eric's videos you
killing it with the gear says it was a
like that is something
testing doesn't do people complain like
advances you know how we complain about
armor and things they are nuclear right
now there's five because my inventory
that does nothing and I hate that that
like vision has sentiments that change
the game based on the build and all that
stuff so they're common as far as I'm
concerned I'm definitely the thing that
I only feel that I I think hurts them
and you're gonna make guys may disagree
is I feel because it's so based on
realism and you have the human element
right and there's no like destiny has
magic and mysticism like division you're
shooting a cry and a hoodie a lot of
times not wrong right so so for some you
know for the tactical guys they're cool
but for some people it may take them out
of Ellen and I guess that was my little
thing with them sometimes I even if
maybe they had it zombie something you
know just to kind of you know make it
feel like why I'm shooting this guy in
the hoodie 35,000 to us and they don't
feel spongy I just want to see how they
address that that's my only weakness in
with destiny obviously I'm biased yes
that's these in a very bad place when it
started and I'm saying it's been
improving watch them damn flashpoints my
boy he burnt this with me ever since
but the thing is this right now with
warmind alone people are just loving
those improvements and like King said
look where it's at as far as most games
played people they're starting to
understand why the hell people like the
game the beginning the hark or the grind
you know that's what destiny guys like
in good rewards you know I'm saying like
these catalysts and stuff like that I
will agree with with our Matic so if
forsaken bombs it's over it doesn't even
matter
buy it for C I have from good authority
your box you know and a lot of the
content creators from the destined
community that went to the community
summit they know of things that I can't
say and that you know there's NDA we
can't talk about it but at the end of
the day it is it sounds amazing
you know saying and from what I touched
at e3 we gambit and Eric's I know you
touch again or what did you feel about I
liked a lot yeah it was really good I
thought gambit was something unique you
know a piece looking forward going
through that portal and throwing down
another ball on people absolutely I
think destiny is in a strong position if
Forsaken
livers think they got it look like it's
gonna deliver but I not going remember
we've been bird and I get it I totally
get it we've all been burned we felt why
did this thing come out the way it did
you know I'm saying of course I'm buying
I'm taking nothing away from division
I'm taking anthem could be phenomenal as
well I'm not taking anything
this was my gut is telling me because in
the Gulf things would what a bond test
I'd be eyes I didn't even think destiny
two would get to where it is now when
people are playing it it was bad man
people were laughing at me in bunches
why are you going to destiny to see
those think that is it strong enough to
carry over a little way to February in
March
that's a good point and the reason why I
have confidence sovereign on you making
fantastic point the reason why I have
confidence is because since then not
only has buns you've been supremely
transparent not only do we get updates
every month they've even changed now the
destruction the only argument that kills
what I'm saying is what Eric's is saying
is that divisions coming with them free
updates that's a big deal that's not to
be understated you know I mean having
free content whoa
that's something look at monster world
yeah but that's what I got out of this
is that was pretty much cat cards going
over a little bit so I want to add
checking I know the boxes you got a run
I'm assuming right there you got a run
real quick and then um Erik's do we got
you because I know we got you a little
long man and I want to hold you up to
what how you doing a little like Steve
okay cool cool so we'll blaze through
that the topic with the crossovers arm
solve are you okay let us hold it on the
Yeti but honestly I honestly it didn't
really fit you want to relate one thing
back to actually add them destiny go for
it go for the book it is you right and
not necessarily with Yeti but with
everything that's going on with like
Microsoft looking to open up their
walled garden more right like play with
Nintendo minecraft fighting fortnight
hmm think any of these games anthem
Division two in destiny obviously
doesn't apply a none of these apply to
switch but do you think any of these
games further that discussion it said
okay you think any of these games
further that discussion about in
PlayStation jumping into this cross
plate thing being pushed into it I think
if there's any game doing it's gonna be
for tonight nothing else nothing else
nothing else yeah I don't know this is
gonna put pressure on on any to party to
get that done before tonight I think
it's I don't think it's this Jen if it's
to happen I mean me it may gotta be
[ __ ] the cross progression I think
they're gonna cave on that eventually
yeah at the cross play yeah I don't see
they just I mean Nate a market leader
they have a dominant position
there's no reason and even though it's
anti-consumer yes of course you know
there but there's no reason for them to
do it i dishes my gut i don't know what
everybody else's thing but we're gonna
move on everyone's got their lord addict
man you got a fun one listen let's book
in this last topic with uh crossovers me
this topic are for your air ox um so
okay with the the crossover from we were
talking about early the monster hunter
and and final fantasy you don't see this
a whole lot in the industry at all
actually most that's kind of like with
the whole so anything it's like you're
kind of my competitors so why we cross
cross marketing our games like that what
what that happening what is another game
that you would like to see a crossover
of of two different game could be
anything it could even the only thing I
would speculate is keep it don't cross
over consoles because that will never
happen
like third-party stuff that is a in any
realm that is a possibility but like
Sony like Master Chief's never gonna be
like battle royale I mean how is it I
mean like I'm kind of I would love to
see like a load of Smash Brothers where
my favorite my favorite series oh yeah
imagine that where I imagine if they did
actually do this in life
in light of like let's just say right
Nintendo winter winter Microsoft like
you know what since we do this cross
play thing how would you like to take
one your Microsoft characters and throw
into Smash Brothers give me like a
master
because the crazy thing is right I mean
like obviously we've had although it's
not strictly I mean you look like
metaphor but obviously we've got snake
in Smash Brothers we've got pac-man
showed up Sonic show up of course like
for a while Sega or Nintendo used to be
like head-to-head like Microsoft and
Sony were so like that's not that's not
too crazy but I mean imagine if they did
that and they actually went to like
everyone right if they did this is nope
this attempt to be like a big piece
pyrite and go to like a get one of your
characters go to Sony hey give us one of
your characters and suddenly like
Nintendo's like Smash Brothers has like
the big you can do those big battle be
don't go crazy you know would be cool
what's that is if okay first up I'm
gonna say this right now any kind of
Super Smash Brothers type game has ever
made for the other platforms they go had
the house source admitted to Nintendo
would be cool if like right now I think
it would be more for possibly in Sony
not Sony Microsoft in nintendo because
they have a better relationship at the
moment but uh I would like it would be
cool if like Nintendo made a super smash
brothers for a place a for Xbox with all
the Xbox characters yeah and then there
is a cross play between their Super
Smash Brothers and our Super Smash
Brothers that you can use people from
that game to that game that you can't
use any of the other ones from the other
games you can actually have that your
company your console possibly Xbox
Nintendo topic I mean from me it's like
I think the crossover thing is just just
a cool thing I look at a game like buy
Tekken 7 hmm and I think what Namco
Bandai and these guys were out in these
guys I think they got it down because
I'll never forget my face when I saw a
cool me jump in that screen and now only
did he jump in they were like he's
cannon the story so I'm like wow didn't
you know since then it's been you know
he's Howard from fatal fury and not this
one Final Fantasy 15 and I'm just like
wow and it doesn't feel like sometimes
people do guest characters but I think
from which rumor that was critic
Namco is kill and then a lot Eric you
gotta back me up on this man jump sauce
bro yes good people they're like
ichigo's my date I was like you guys are
idiots if you take tone and jump stop
putting Ichigo in a game well I think
they've actually said since then like
when I caressed they show you in the
trailer obviously like what's the name
light and so like he's not ISO so
everyone kind of saw that in the trailer
they're like oh cool so the fellow you
see death no shorty that means to me a
thumb war but if I live you said that's
they'll be in the story but you won't
play as them it could it could
potentially limit the roster I kind of
feel like that was like like you know
Loki false advertising like you're
showing these characters fight each
other you show Light Yagami and Ryu just
randomly like yo you can't use them no
[Applause]
someone needs to make a montage yeah
because I feel like to a certain degree
right
this was also like the year of the bait
because they were like me skate and it
wasn't skate there's actually Funko pops
obviously cuz we got like we got the the
light thing I think there was something
else as well there was something else
that came in they were like four or five
or five different things it's like Louis
saw that what do you feel about guest
characters the video games that whole
it's it's great because it takes you
know shakes up the formula of that game
you know and let you know that people
are willing to do silly stuff with their
with their uh with their properties you
know like killer instinct on on xbox and
they had one of the battletoads in there
they had to get one point
what's the killer instinct they had the
female master chief over that dead or
alive and um so that stuff is fun man I
love to see that like we were talking
with Lord for we last last week I would
love to see like you know like Halo
vehicles and stuff I would love trying
to make them blow the budget
guest characters the Warthog imagine
like if you have a juggernaut coming at
you in state of the cage and you walk
out and you walk out of your house and
like a mule in your armor or something
like that taking no stuff like that it's
just cool it's fun rolling you know and
and I think what it does is it
introduces it introduces characters from
that property into another property that
maybe doesn't have the crossover in
fandoms or like be invested in a
different type of game that they
normally wouldn't be so yeah yeah shell
desert oh he said general Rams and kill
instinct - yes right my next thing is
what do you guys thinks the best
crossover you seen Oh from is Tekken 7
I'm just I'm sorry I'm I'm a second head
I've never seen that before I know you
guys are the anime guys I know jump for
us Carly got a few guys and was after
but I've never seen it like just to see
those historic franchises we know they
kind of messed with the you know the
street fighter vs Tekken you know I'm
saying in in but it was really not canon
I think the fact that tekken 7 said this
is canon he killed this person and yeah
i was like well and it he'd look like he
picked some characters they know you
know it's just like okay we throwing him
in like he looked like he fit me the
fighting community went crazy forget
that day when I saw a kuma out there
fighting even the street fighter guys
were like yo I am picking up mekin like
that is its own now like so that was for
me I think the best one is Kingdom
Hearts by far like tonight you know when
it comes to a lot of these games have
crossover sub splash in them but Kingdom
Hearts is built from that like the
cordilla crossover yeah Kombat vs. DC
Universe is cool I thought it was you
know that's something you just didn't
expect to see I would love to see people
die in it but you know that was gonna
happen but for me old-school and King
King who knows it's like remember
fighters megamix from the Sega Saturn
back in the day they had everybody and
their mother was in that game everybody
from Sega stables in that game you even
had a playable car from like um from
like from like Sega rally or something
like that a car yeah
what what I would like to see is a kart
racing with all the major characters
like you have sonic versus crash
bandicoot where's Mario you know you
tune with for gravity hammer and I
actually like to use my switch so put
them all like cradles versus Master
Chief I can see it happen in the car
racing type of world when you get all
warped out you have a nice little story
around it like Eggman gets together with
a truck skills Eggman like this is a lot
of people putting some good suggestions
in the chat man sold Cal a lot of food
good good stuff is good topic man if
anybody got anything else on the
character just get the pole and get the
outro so we get a lot out of it I think
most most hundred forty is like King or
like they've done so many I mean like
they just like you know in some of them
they never made out Japan because
obviously like I fear attrition of stuff
but they've had like crossover dude like
manga and anime they've had crossovers
like actual my brands ahead like Uniqlo
crossover so you just get like close
from there like in game they've had like
that I want some most shown and John
they've had like game crossover so
there's obviously like Zelda they just
had so many they just they just grabbed
left right center sorry so no and also
like another like Ross I'm a fighter
that I I missed they were as always
getting even one of them but you read
what Tatsunoko vs. Capcom so many things
oh we gotta be a we would have to do a
dedicated this so we can go off of it
you know what the sad part loners I've
never got a chance to plead Oh what
where can I get is it even on a we man
it was a Wii game it was me I pulled out
I even bought the occasion see for that
just for that game
oh now let me ask y'all caught me eyes
cuz I almost hardcore gotcha me like did
they have like each of the the GeForce
characters do they have their unique
thing like what am i man Mark had a
boomerang did they like did they have
they thing attributes were ok I'm coming
ok I got I've never seen I heard of it
never played it man really good Eric for
that one now is a gem that was a Jim
let's grab this ago them so we got the
pole for coming up for next week so are
we gonna knock the dust from e3 2018 has
settled this is courtesy of Lord King
y'all by the way which of these titles
is your most anticipated game for
purchase a ghost of Tsushima be
cyberpunk 2077 and I know Eric's got
some things talked about that
but under NDA see Last of Us 2 or D I
don't care Gears pop mobile and Gears
tactics for the win make fun of my gears
tactics dude that game's gonna be fun
please Rock the aisle people when it
goes up tomorrow on Twitter Lord Eric's
an absolute pleasure all day I was like
look I gotta get him out on time and
follow me for so long this was a dream
interview you're definitely on my balls
on a bucket list but stuff that I've
always wanted to do as an interview
first of all where can you find people
find you and what do you have going on
I second finds predominately on youtube
so youtube.com slash Eric's T also me on
twitter just Eric's and obviously to 6
on Twitter he's 2 6 9 2 which is crazy
so cause we're yeah he won a game of I
saw like a
from Twitter where he won a game in a
Mario Tennis and I was like yo that man
is not rotating his chair like I guess
kind of like sort of the downtown moment
so we're just like dipping into all the
stuff post III kind of turn us all ramp
up now just on coverage for like all the
key pillars now someone's hunter destiny
division and anthem just a on them so
yeah if you enough follow those keep it
keep it looked absolutely pleasure man
this guy i'ma tell you guys this guy's
fantastic huh
if your last game is wrong get over
there and get subscribe and also this
man has some of the best the IRL series
the in real life series are some of the
best V logs I've ever seen it really
gives you a feeling of being at these
convened in the one that you did in
Japan was awesome that's a dream of mine
that I've always wanted to do and shout
out to you and your homie that went out
there and just really gave the dated
eggs but they even wrote the bullet
train y'all wrote the bullet it was
awesome he even did his work in wasn't
it like a tornado a tsunami something
was going on Lord Eric's give to you
you're he's out there do natural
disasters giving me that content man
Eric's this this man got the best thumb
nose in the biz all if there's anything
like I like to the content creators that
like their thumbnails is designed after
our template and you know that's then
why I would say the red dragon he has
that kind of template you know it says
is you know you have like horror
nightmares when you see red dragon that
goes on there Ares got those like timid
black those those great fault with it
it's like it's like you would think that
font wouldn't go with what he has in the
back but somehow he does it because even
though we didn't have a chance
get him today pour on the I'm assuming
he also does the video editing and stuff
like that behind a seat like he's like
we we've kind of a content together and
then I I had a video he does live
streams and I saw like how old that
really nice fantastic team again like
the editing the live streams the whole
thing then please support these guys
good guys in the community what you guys
support them and Lord addict wicked find
people find you what do you have going
on right now you can't find me anywhere
man I'm on this this ex-con grind before
the broken ex-con Dilys my save file
again okay like there's a chance I could
go in there today let's go start trying
to beat it that way when I do go in
there's daylight at least I beat it I'm
baking a 2k game fix your game I do want
to thank Lord irx way I you know I've
been following you for a while too I
remember uh the I I probably showed that
Zotoh how to fight all that arbiter
probably eighty people because they'll
be like whoa what kind of arbors in
setup like I got the perfect video
appreciate you for coming on man like
yeah I've actually been looking forward
to this actually uh week me and the lore
kognito met you at e3 last year in
casting met you and to six industry it
was all of us we actually did meet you
quickly industry that one time I forgot
about that you're right
mm-hmm no doubt man Lord sovereign what
you got going on let me see yeah well
Lord Eric's thank you for coming through
man I I don't I'm not in the destiny
like these but I have to say that when I
was playing that's the I - I'm always on
VG 24/7 and when I needed to know where
there was every Friday morning I was
like love your content fantastic in here
let me see real quick for the patreon
guys and know we had to pay these bills
first of the month
or Cognito and I were sort of we sort of
spaced it today so guys are gonna take
care of you next week make sure we take
care of all of our patreon subscribers
um also big shout out to Amazon Italy
who's trying to take away the title from
Walmart Canada yeah they're in the show
they'll into selling blood born to
blood-borne Twitter's been going bananas
okay he gonna be on it Lord King where
can I find people find you what you got
going on uh first of all this is the
early birthday present for me oh you
have owned a log King tomorrow to say
this is probably one of my most
anticipated interviews and I'm not
slighting anyone I'm really I'm up for
everybody but we you specifically um
like what attic said the content you
gave for Zelda it's a lot of things I
can just go back and you're my reference
point for damn near all of it so
everything that you have put out either
I have watched it and glancing or
watched it to completion and I've you
hit that like and I definitely subscribe
and I'm definitely like spreading the
gospel of your channel when you sign on
and because I'm getting out of my
streaming and stuff together you're
inspiring me to make sure that I come
with an A game and so that I don't put
up a video and it's like it's not that
quality presentation and your first
impression is your best impression and
your first impression on me was the
greatest impression so I just want to
say I am very happy among anybody that's
even watching understands what's going
on right now I'm fanboying completely
but I need a picture
okay he was liked by the visual but if I
had my back turned he had said something
I would turn around out the arrow sees
the reason I know how to use more than
like two weapons on monster on try to
like you know I want to use a different
weapon let's see where Alex made a video
on also I like this shadow if I finally
cracked two thousand followers Jesus and
that was the hard work from e3 max I
appreciate everything thank y'all so
much
and this I'm really at you know really a
lost words I can't blow they and say how
much high praises for this man as much
as I can but they appreciate you giving
your time and you know even you know
come here this is this is amazing day
for me happy born day to King real quick
I shouted JDK many chat for the donation
mark associated acquiring Japanese
developer to make the biggest slash in
next-gen
saying economist but thank you so much
it again for the UH for the contribution
and of course here it's meat law [ __ ]
needle here again thanks again Lord air
Eric's just a tremendous guest
tremendous pleasure all man so much fun
make sure the Lord's everybody hit that
like I described also the ILP patreon
like Lord soft said will be up will take
care of everybody the next week we just
want to play respect obviously to the
great Eric's we didn't have to get it
right there but we will take care all
that please subscribe to the inner
circle network media outlets links are
in description south the lordy boxes for
coming through you know I'm saying we
got 22 will be up you have flash play 21
up it was a great discussion on our
destiny what's going on right now
getting ready for forsaken Lord Chi back
to a handle the audio later tonight in
the stamps with the time stands to be up
everybody
enjoy your sunny but also make sure
y'all give King that happy birthday
y'all King David and say who did that
for you
[Laughter]
good